[Musique]
vous allez mettre une rose en ts et une
rose la plus ancienne de la réunion
puisqu'elle date de 1810 est cette rose
porte le nom de rose bourbon l'une des
plus anciennes présentes dans nos cours
créole aujourd'hui elle prend racine
dans les jardins du palais de la source
deux cents ans après sa découverte ces
particularités sont sa résistance à la
sécheresse en truck est également à
pousser dans n'importe quel endroit de
novateur et donc c'est une rose qui est
très adapté qui est très parfumée on
aurait à vue les difficultés qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans notre milieu de
production anti cole d'avoir ce genre de
rose et voir l'utilisé aussi pour des
faits nouveaux
et pour que cette rose retrouve ses
lettres de noblesse le département en
partenariat avec le jardin botanique de
mascarin et l'association jardins
créoles lancent leur aux bourbons tour
un recensement à l'échelle de tout le
territoire des variétés de roses bourbon
encore florissante dans les jardins
réunionnais les gens vont avoir des
outils des plaquettes
une information qui vont
leur permettre d'identifier eux-mêmes ce
qu'ils ont dans leur cour la rose de
leur grand mère ce qui ce dont ils se
souviennent et c'est donc ils vont
participer eux-mêmes et nous dire nous
appeler éventuellement à mascarin ou à
l'association jardins créoles et nous
dire voilà moi j'ai cette rose je veux
je veux pouvoir l'identifier
il me semble que c'est une rose ancienne
une rose bourbon venez voir de toutes
les ruses pour bourg recensés mascarin
va ainsi créer une collection botanique
de référence de rosiers de bourbon les
horticulteurs profiteront également de
cette collecte pour faire émerger une
nouvelle filière de production locale de
l'areuse bourmaud pourra sélectionner il
faut qu'on ait la panel assez large de
variétés et en même temps l'association
fait un travail jardin créole monstrueux
en termes de ventes de sa présence déjà
dans tout les points de lille et de
recherche de reconnaissance de ce qu'on
a
parce que ces rosiers qui sont en rayon
le plus c'est de les avoir multiplié et
de développer de façon locale
[Musique]